Esta es en realidad una presentación de dos horas que doy a estudiantes de secundaria
recortada a tres minutos.
Todo comenzó un día en un avión, camino hacia TED
siete años atrás.
En el asiento de al lado
se encontraba una estudiante de secundaria, una adolescente
que venía de una familia realmente pobre.
Quería hacer algo con su vida,
y me hizo una simple y pequeña pregunta.
Ella dijo, "¿Qué lleva al éxito?"
Y entonces me sentí realmente mal,
porque no podía darle una buena respuesta.
Entonces, me bajé del avión y vine a TED.
Y pensé, ¡Dios!, estoy en una habitación rodeado de personas exitosas.
¿Por qué no les pregunto qué les ayudó a ser exitosos,
para enseñárselo a los jóvenes?
Entonces aquí estamos, después de siete años y 500 entrevistas,
y voy a decirles, lo que realmente lleva al éxito.
y que hace actuar a los miembros de TED.
Lo primero es la Pasión
Freeman Thomas dijo, "Soy impulsado por mi pasión"
Las personas en TED lo hacen por amor, no por dinero.
Carol Colleta dijo, "Yo pagaría a alguien por hacer lo que yo hago".
Lo curioso es que,
Si lo haces por amor, el dinero viene de todas maneras.
¡Trabajo! Rupert Murdoch me dijo, "Todo es trabajo duro,
Nada viene fácilmente. Pero me he divertido bastante".
¿Dijo diversión? ¿Rupert? ¡Sí!
A las personas en TED les divierte el trabajo. Y trabajan muy duro.
Yo pensé, ellos no son adictos al trabajo, son amantes del trabajo.
¡Ser bueno! Alex Garden dijo, "Para ser exitoso debes dedicarte a algo,
y ser muy bueno en ello".
No hay magia, todo es practicar, practicar, practicar.
Y también es enfocarse. Norman Jewison me dijo,
"Yo pienso que todo tiene que ver con enfocarse en una sola cosa".
Empujarte, David Gallo dijo, "Debes empujarte.
física y mentalmente, debes empujarte, empujarte, empujarte".
Debes empujarte a través de la timidez, y las dudas.
Goldie Hawn dijo, "Siempre tuve dudas.
No era lo suficientemente buena, no era lo suficientemente inteligente,
no pensé que lo lograría".
Ahora bien, nunca es fácil empujarte,
y es por eso que inventaron a las madres. (Risas).
Frank Gehry me dijo,
"Mi madre me empujó".
¡Servir! Sherwin Nuland dijo, "Ha sido un privilegio servir como doctor".
Ahora muchos niños me dicen que quieren ser millonarios.
Y lo primero que les digo es,
"Ok, pero no pueden servirse a ustedes mismos,
deben servirles a otros con algo de valor.
Porque esa es la manera en que las personas se vuelven ricas".
¡Ideas! Bill Gates dijo, "Tuve una idea:
fundar la primera compañía de programas para microcomputadoras".
Diría que fue una muy buena idea.
Y no hay magia en la creatividad en cuanto a ideas se refiere,
es sólo hacer cosas bastantes simples.
Y doy muchas evidencias de ello.
Persistencia. Joe Kraus dijo,
"Persistencia es la razón número uno del éxito"
Tienes que persistir a través del fracaso, y de CRAP (mierda),
que por supuesto significa "Criticas, Rechazo, Assholes (idiotas) y Presión".
(Risas)
Entonces, la respuesta a esta pregunta es simple:
paga $ 4000 y ven a TED.
Si eso falla, ten en cuenta las 8 razones, y créeme,
estas 8 grandes razones, son las que llevan al éxito.
Muchas gracias TED, ¡y gracias por las entrevistas!